I'm only 16 and I can't vote and I don't
have a lot of power in in political
realms or in different places like that
but I do know that my voice matters my
name is chief eschaton Matthew I'm 16
years old I'm a front lines climate
activists spokesperson for my generation
hip-hop artists and youth director of
Earth Guardians I became an activist
when I was six years old I hopped up
onto a stage and I decided that I wanted
to deliver a speech about the world
about climate change telling the story
from the perspective of a six-year-old
kid that was learning all these things
in the media and seeing that the world
was falling apart as a member of the
generation that's gonna be inheriting
this planet that's very concerning for
me because I feel like we're leaving
future generations a planet much worse
than we found it I am one of 21 youth
plaintiffs they are suing the federal
government for violating our
constitutional right written in the
Constitution to life liberty and
property for failing to take action on
climate change and protect our future
standing rock is not just about the
Dakota access pipeline it's about every
pipeline every fossil fuel project every
infrastructure project that threatens
our voices our future our water our
children this is showing the world that
there is no place any longer in this
world for fossil fuels never has there
been a generation with more potential to
create change in the world and to shape
the direction of our culture than our
generation does we have the creativity
the innovation the strength and and the
wisdom of those that came before us and
access to so much technology is so much
information that we are really going to
be the ones that are defining the way
that the world is going to work not only
in the future but we are also here today
we are the present generation and our
voices matter